[Music]
on this friday night getting a handle on
covet 19 in canada
children now form the majority of cases
health count of the regulations are
working extremely hard how long before
this group gets vaccinated the promise
in a pill this is a very very promising
result pfizer's new line of protection
against the virus the rogers rumble
obesity justice decides who's in charge
plus seeking safety they are leaving
their safe houses and they were
disappointed and hopeless the afghans on
the run will canada help
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin with breaking news and the family
feud that has often been compared to
succession a tv drama the battle over
control of the board at rogers
communication came to a head at bc
supreme court today a justice ruled
edward rogers was within his power to
remove and replace five directors
global's paul johnson is at bc supreme
court in vancouver with the latest paul
robin the rogers family feud is now set
to escalate to the appeals court this
afternoon justice shelly fitzpatrick
ruled that the bc laws that govern the
company's incorporation mean his control
of voting rights in the family trust
give him control of the board not the
opposing faction that had been led by
his mother and his sisters so
that was a moment of clarity for the
business community and the markets one
they'd been hoping for but
lawyers representing the sisters and the
mother immediately said they're going to
appeal this and that's an appeal that's
likely to hit the appeals court early
next week so what we're faced with now
is the prospect of continued legal and
corporate maneuvering
or as some observers are speculating
because this is essentially a family
affair maybe this is something that
eventually gets settled over a kitchen
table at some point here in the coming
days and weeks after all the stakes are
extremely high on the line here is the
prestige of one of canada's best-known
business families and of course what is
going to be the future of the rogers
company one of our leading and best
known corporate brands and at a critical
time in their story just as they're
poised to close their multi-billion
dollar acquisition of shaw
communications everybody's wondering how
and if this is going to affect that so
as you mentioned
if you're a fan of hbo's succession but
you don't have hbo we've got kind of our
own canadian version playing out up here
stay tuned robin
probably one of the most interesting
business stories in a long time paul
thanks so much for that
now to some cautious optimism about the
state of the pandemic in canada new
federal modeling shows major progress in
getting the fourth wave under control
after surpassing 4 000 cases a day in
september that number is now averaging
around 2 200. but keep in mind the rate
of decline is starting to slow canada's
top doctor says we're not out of the
woods yet
now's not the time to let our guard down
we may still be in for a challenging
winter and maintaining a cautious
approach can help us keep us safer as we
move indoors with the arrival of colder
weather
one of the big unknowns headed into
winter is when kids under 12 will get
access to vaccines they are not yet
protected against the virus and now they
account for the bulk of canada's new
infections abigail beeman has that story
tonight
while covet cases are decreasing overall
the light green line in this new
modeling shows cases among the youngest
canadians spiked during the fourth wave
and are still the highest among all age
groups dr tam says outbreaks in schools
and day cares remain small involving
fewer than four cases which suggest
sensitive detection and rapid response
to control spread reality right this is
where a lot of the cases are
the good parts about that is that we
know that most kids who do get coveted
do well of course contributing to the
cases children under 12 can't yet be
vaccinated as for 12 plus what's
exciting about some of this is that what
we're seeing in adolescents is that
their uptake of the vaccine is very
close to the overall adult uptake and
this is how you see the vaccine working
we don't see the burden of cases in that
age group anymore it's been a week since
the u.s gave the green light for
children 5 to 11 to get the shot but
there are no updates for us in canada i
would say to all parents that health
canada regulators are working extremely
hard prioritize the review for this
vaccine but they need to do due
diligence and it will be in weeks and
not months in the face of good
indicators overall the top doctors
warned we could be in for a challenging
winter compounded by flu season
the prime minister sent a message by
getting his flu shot on camera in
saskatchewan we are seeing some kids in
hospital with other respiratory
illnesses
so we need to remember that it's about
coping it's also about the other
illnesses that we do typically see in
the winter for kids so getting your flu
shot is huge i suspect that the flu
season this year is not going to be as
mild as last year because our
restrictions are not as strict dr tam
warning we're not out of the woods yet
and now is not the time to drop public
health measures with a potentially rough
winter ahead she says will probably be
in a better position in the spring robin
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
now to some promising news about another
potentially game-changing treatment for
kova 19. one day after merck's
anti-viral pill was approved in the uk
pfizer says it has its own drug that
proved highly effective in a clinical
trial jamie morocco reports on how these
treatments work and the difference they
could make in the fight against kova 19.
there may be new weapons in the fight
against covid19
pills oral medications that represent
the next frontier of treatment and their
early results have canadian scientists
excited if you can reduce
hospitalization by roughly 90 percent
this is
a very very promising result so much so
pfizer concluded its preliminary trial
of 775 participants early after it saw
high-risk adults with covid who received
the antiviral paxlavid three to five
days after symptoms began had a dramatic
reduction in hospitalizations and deaths
very high efficacy comes even to us as a
surprise exceeds our most
visionary expectations here's how it
works protease enzymes function like a
pair of scissors cutting protein chains
so the virus can quickly replicate the
protein inhibitor pax level is designed
to block the scissors blades so it can't
cut and then it can't multiply having
another layer of
a way to treat the virus directly as
opposed to trying to prevent the virus
is an effective strategy
and it's something that adds a lot of a
lot of tools to our toolbox one that's
cheaper and easier to administer than iv
treatments like monoclonal antibodies
critically it could also be easier to
mass produce experts say and distribute
globally
already drug maker merck has sold
millions of dollars of its coven 19
anti-viral pill malnu piravir which has
shown to reduce severe covet outcomes by
50 percent it was approved in the uk
thursday i know that the pill does not
take away from the vaccination the
vaccination is still really really
important but this will reduce my
symptoms hopefully therefore the
infection will not take a hold on my
chest and i won't end up in hospital
mark's pill is under review by health
canada and the u.s fda
i do know that our regulatory colleagues
are working
as fast as they can pfizer says it
hasn't yet made submissions to
regulators here but it does plan to ask
for emergency use authorization in the
u.s it hopes to get data to them later
this month robin a marker in toronto
flags on federal buildings will be
raised to full mast on sunday ahead of
honoring canadian veterans the flags
will then be lowered monday to recognize
indigenous veterans day they will be
raised again before being lowered on
november 11th remembrance day flags on
federal buildings have flown at
half-mast nationwide since may 30th
after the discovery of unmarked graves
at the site of a former residential
school in kamloops the government worked
with the assembly of first nations to
honor veterans and indigenous peoples
and will fly the national center for
truth and reconciliation's survivor's
flag in ottawa
to afghanistan now where countless
families who help the canadian military
are still trapped desperate to escape
the taliban up until now many have hid
in safe houses waiting for the safe
passage promised by canada but after
months of inaction and dwindling funds
those houses are now shutting down
jeff semple reports
hundreds of afghans and their families
who supported canada's military mission
have been hiding for months in these
secret safe houses organized by canadian
veterans and paid for with private
donations
but money and time have just run out do
you know where you're going to go with
your family
we don't know exactly where we have to
go we're hiding ali's face because he
used to work for the canadian forces
last summer his family left their home
in kandahar and came to kabul where they
were told canada was sending a rescue
flight before the taliban took over ali
has received approval to move to canada
but his wife and some of his children
are still waiting for their applications
to be processed the family has been
living in a safe house but today they
and hundreds of others were told they
have to leave
today check a lot of our houses but it's
too expensive to rent other end and
now it's coming cold
couple there's some snow and there's a
lot of cold but you know we don't have
uh the blankets today um we have had to
essentially evict everybody that we've
been keeping in safe uh
in safe houses since july amenlara the
canadian veterans group managing the
safe houses raised two million dollars
in private donations but after months of
sheltering and feeding two thousand
afghans those funds have run out the
group says it has no choice but to close
the safe houses these people
very potentially could be harmed very
needlessly
because our government is not moving
fast enough to help them amanlara says
the canadian government has processed
fewer than one percent of the refugee
applications it's received
and while the government has committed
around 80 million dollars in
humanitarian aid to the region it has so
far refused to provide any money
directly for the safe houses global news
asked the canadian government numerous
times whether it has any plans to
provide funding for the safe houses in
afghanistan in an emailed written
statement a spokesperson said that due
to security considerations they do not
discuss operational details of their
missions abroad they were disappointed
and hopeless where they should go these
afghan refugees just arrived in canada
but are worried for their family members
back home with few flights available
they were driven out of the country by a
canadian veterans group
a six-hour treacherous trek across the
border to pakistan but those road
evacuations have now stalled a lot of
the neighboring countries are a bit um
frozen at the moment there's different
requirements we're not seeing many
people get out by land do you have
anywhere to go tonight
um not yet when we called ali back he
just spent hours looking for another
place to live they didn't give us a food
today and they told us if we don't leave
the house we will cut the electrode
electric
and
the water line tool he says his family
is running low on money
and
hope
jeff sample global news toronto
canada's economy got a boost in october
the national unemployment rate reached a
pandemic error low 31 000 jobs were
added last month bringing the jobless
rate down to 6.7 percent it marks the
fifth straight month that the
unemployment rate has dropped the hard
hit retail sector was one industry that
saw a bump in jobs but it was offset by
a drop in employment in accommodation
and food services
in alberta a cabinet minister has quit
after allegations of heavy drinking at
work devin driessen says he resigned as
alberta's minister of agriculture and
forestry to focus on his health though
he will stay on as an mla dreishan was
named in a lawsuit filed last month
against premier jason kenney's office in
the lawsuit a former staffer claims she
was wrongly fired after speaking out
about a toxic work environment the
allegations have not been proven in
court
coming up the video evidence in the case
of three men charged with the murder of
a black man
in the u.s the trial of three white men
charged in the murder of ahmad avery is
underway last february aubry was out for
a jog when he was fatally shot the
suspects were only charged after video
of the incident stoked public outrage
now there are already accusations of
discrimination at play in the trial
after a nearly all-white jury was
selected jackson proskow reports and a
warning some of the images in this story
may be disturbing
gregory michael and travis mcmichael
sought to confront mr arbory and took
their guns with them to do it
on trial for murder assault and
attempted kidnapping the three men who
chased down and killed a mod arbory now
face a judge and jury in opening
statements prosecutors allege travis
mcmichael greg mcmichael and their
neighbor william roddy bryan took it
upon themselves to hunt down arbory
based on assumptions the defendants
assumed the worst about this drama
artery and made their driveway decisions
the mcmichaels insists they were acting
in self-defense while attempting to
conduct a citizen's arrest of arbory who
was out jogging
they told police they suspected arbory
was armed and responsible for recent
burglaries in their neighborhood they're
there to detain a mod arbory for the
police this is what the law allows
the defense focused on the months
leading up to the shooting when arbory
was sometimes seen walking around a
house under construction the same
property he visited the morning of the
shooting there's no evidence arbory ever
did anything but look around the site
the accused only called 9-1-1 after they
began chasing him we think
the only right verdict is not guilty on
each and every count in this
indictment race will play a central role
in the trial there have been comparisons
to a modern day lynching
according to investigators travis
mcmichael who shot arbory allegedly used
a racial slur in the aftermath i'm very
anxious
about the trial beginning
i'm very hopeful that we'll get the
correct verdict the makeup of the jury
with only one black person has raised
concern
the defense struck 11 of 12 prospective
black jurors from the pool drawing a
rare rebuke from the judge this court
has found that there appears to be
intentional
discrimination in the panel like the
murder of george floyd in minneapolis
charges in arbory's death likely would
not have happened were it not for the
video which surfaced months later
now the accused not only face
prosecution in georgia but also a
separate trial on federal hate crime
charges
jackson prosco global news washington
still ahead the call to arms in
ethiopia's war as rebel forces advance
you're watching global national
[Music]
in mexico gunmen opened fire at a
popular resort killing two suspected
drug dealers it happened near the hyatt
ziva riviera cancun an all-inclusive
resort in puerto morelos the dramatic
attack sent tourists scrambling for
cover in the hotel police are calling it
a confrontation between rival gangs
in ethiopia the military is calling on
former soldiers to rejoin the ranks to
fight advancing rebel forces the rebels
from the northern region of tigre
announced a new alliance with other
anti-government groups they're
reportedly advancing towards the capital
but the government is digging in it's
declared a state of emergency and called
on residents to pick up arms to defend
the city this week marked one year since
the conflict erupted in that time
thousands of people have been killed
up next the push to make global trade
greener
thousands of young people marched
through glasgow today demanding more
action over their future at the cop 26
climate summit among them was
high-profile activist greta tunberg who
has accused world leaders of making
hollow commitments and pretending to
take climate change seriously speaking
at the rally she went as far to say the
summit was a failure
they are actively creating loopholes and
shaping frameworks to benefit themselves
and to continue profiting from this
destructive system a two-week long
celebration of business as usual and
blah blah blah
there is a high bar to meet the climate
challenge take ships they're huge
emission hogs but they're still vital
for trade and travel as crystal gomezing
reports a canadian company has come up
with a solution that sounds as simple as
charging your phone
measuring by volume nearly 90 percent of
world trade goods are moved on water the
international council on clean transport
says if international shipping was a
country it would be the sixth largest
emitter of greenhouse gas emissions
based on 2015 data i spent years
building vessels and seeing around the
world the impact
that we have today with pollution
brent perry is the ceo of shift power
swap stations provide fresh energy
within minutes the canadian clean energy
company won a contract to equip 20
vessels of the port of singapore with
its pay-as-you-go power swap battery
system think of the rechargeable battery
you pop onto your power tools but on a
much larger scale the project will ramp
up to 1600 vessels within the port's
infrastructure powerswap a practical
solution to reduce the impact of climate
change
and by next year shifts power swap will
also be used on boats in the uk to
transfer workers to and from a wind farm
we'll be charging them both on shore and
using the wind generators themselves to
charge the ships so these guys will be
able to go from being a heavy polluting
element on a wind farm which is a green
energy producer to now being a partner
if you want in zero emission delivery of
the whole entire ecosystem of the wind
farm that holistic chain approach is
gaining speed ahead of cop26 nine major
companies including amazon and ikea
signed a pledge to only move cargo on
ships using zero carbon fuels by 2040
but greening the entire industry may be
as challenging as freeing a stuck ship
in the suez
a patchwork of electric and cleaner
burning fuels is likely the
international maritime organization has
set 2050 as its deadline for shipping
companies to cut the amount of carbon
dioxide emitted by vessels world leaders
meeting here in scotland just steps away
from the river clyde and its rich
shipbuilding history are set to come up
with a plan that will protect global
waterways meanwhile energy and
technology companies such as shift are
also gathering sharing best practices
and hoping to get the attention of those
leaders
crystal gomanson global news
glasgow
and that is global national for this
friday i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is madeira park on the sunshine
coast in british columbia thank you to
the surgic family for sharing the photo
we know they are very loyal viewers
there are beautiful spots all over
canada so please send us your pictures
the email is viewers globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i hope to see
you back here again tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
you